♪ (TRANQUIL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JOHN WILSON: Hey, New York.
There's a lot of stuff
that happened
since the last season
of the show ended.
You had to spend
a whole lot of time inside
and got really close with
just a handful of people.
You got really good
at cutting your own hair
and discovered exciting new ways
to entertain yourself.
But you still found a way
to show up for work every day
and treated yourself
to a vacation
whenever it felt safe.
And just when you thought things
were going back to normal,
the nightmare
just seemed to continue.
A lot of people thought
that we wouldn't be able
to make another season
of the show,
but we did.
And it still has
all your favorite stuff
from the first one.
New York looks
more interesting right now
than it ever has before.
And even though you lost
a lot of what you loved,
it really made you appreciate
what you still have.
So, don't be upset
if you feel like
you missed anything
along the way
because you don't always realize
you're in the middle of history
until it's over.
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
This is John Wilson.
Talk to you soon.